good afternoon ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to the Salzburg summit first
conference the three speakers will first
give two introductory remarks and
afterwards take your questions now
without further ado I first invite the
hosts of the summit federal Chancellor
Sebastian courts together ladies and
gentlemen I would like to welcome you to
this concluding press conference
following our summit here in Salzburg I
would like to thank presidents trusk
and Younker for the good cooperation
we've had and together we will attempt
to give you an overview of what's
happened over the past couple of days
and what we expect to do from here the
two main issues were brexit and
combating illegal migration maybe I
couldn't begin with a few words and
breaks it I think it's important for
both sides to move towards each other to
give a little we've got to avoid a hard
break Syd we've had good discussions of
an informal nature here among the twenty
seven of us we agreed that we would use
October to finalize the negotiations and
then in November we would put a final
line under the negotiations in addition
we talked about migration we managed to
change the trend for the first time in
June by focusing more on protecting
external borders and also in cooperation
with transit countries in combating
illegal migration and trafficking
we've managed to take a further step
today president risk and I have agreed
in our discussions with Egypt and indeed
with North African countries that we are
going to deepen these discussions we've
agreed on more in-depth cooperation on
issues of migration but also issues such
as economic cooperation with Egypt Egypt
is not going for refugee centers at the
same time it has been very efficient in
combating illegal migration over the
past two years
no single vessel has left Egypt
illegally heading for Europe in cases
fresh boats did attempt to leave
illegally towards Europe they were
brought back to Egypt Egypt and the
North African countries can be important
partners for us in preventing ships
heading to Europe and after they rescue
they're being brought back in other
words to the countries of transit only
in this way can we reduce illegal
migration can we destroy the business
model of the smugglers and stop the
drownings in the Mediterranean in
particular redistribution of refugees
within Europe that has been in the past
a major issue this was a secondary
matter during this summit our presidency
is in the obligation of course to deal
with all of those issues which member
states are called upon to tackle I would
admit in this case that I have always
said this I've said this I've been
saying this for years the jury
allocation and redistribution alone is
not the only way of dealing with the
migration issue there has been a certain
amount of dissent with regard to the
redistribution there still is and I
personally feel that disagreement in
this issue will continue beyond the
Austrian presidency so I think it's a
good thing and it's important that we
focus upon external border protection
combating illegal migration dealing with
smugglers and cooperation with North
African countries we also used the time
available to
to consider the Commission's proposals
on Frontex I support fully the proposal
a number of member states feel that they
require further discussion on
sovereignty in rights
I do hope that by the end of the year
we'll be able to achieve an agreement to
strengthen front decks to extend its
mandate and to increase its personnel to
10,000 protecting the external borders
by the end of 2020 we also agreed to
strive for closer cooperation with the
African countries in supporting
development of their countries in other
words economic cooperation cooperation
to make full use of innovation and
progress and supporting their countries
and reducing suffering wherever possible
so in the middle of December together
with a president of the Africa African
Union mr. Kagame will be inviting to a
summit in Vienna and I'd like to thank
President Juncker for his support on
this as well finally a word of thanks to
all of the inhabitants of Salzburg I
know you've had to face a lot of
disruption and massive security and
inevitably a lot of traffic over the
past couple of days in your city I'd
like to thank you nevertheless for your
kindness and your hospitality during
this summit I'm very grateful to the
executive side of things the
administration and the organizers I
think the summit has been very
successful I hope you felt at home here
and as Austrian Federal Chancellor I
very much hope that the images you send
across the globe will encourage a few
tourists here and there to maybe come to
Austria for the holidays next year and
many thanks if you've enjoyed it please
come back privately as well
jf the summit European Council President
Donald Tusk let me start by thanking the
beautiful city of that book the Austrian
new presidency until personally
sebastian for hosting this remarkable
summit it's truly impressive your
hospitality logistic not an empty
compliment it was one of the best
political performance I have ever
congratulations as you mentioned we have
discussed migration internal security
and drags it here in Salzburg the
migration debate
showed that we may not agree on
everything but we agree on the main goal
which is stemming illegal migration to
Europe there was a constructive debate
and good atmosphere and we decided to
continue our focus on what unites us and
what has already brought results this
means strengthening our external borders
as well as strengthening cooperation
with third countries such cooperation
should not be just a migration of
fighting smugglers and traffickers it
should be about a much broader vision of
partnership together with Chancellor
Kurtz
we have started a dialogue with the
Egyptian president and now we can say
that there is a backing from the
European Council for this and similar
dialogues I will meet President al-sisi
on Sunday to take this forward and we
will be reaching out to other African
partners in the coming weeks with
Chancellor couch with the Commission
also with a group of countries
I mean member states in this contexts we
also agreed to organize a family with
the League of Arab states in February
next year in Egypt on internal security
we agreed priorities for immediate
actions that's right the short
determination to take forward the
Commission's proposal for strength and
European Boden's Coast Guard as a
priority at the same time as Chancellor
underlined it is also clear that the
issues regarding sovereignty and the
size of Frontex that will have to be
further discussed in addition we agreed
to step up the fight against all forms
of cybercrime manipulations and
disinformation fires the summit
demonstrated importance our European
cooperation and it's an example of
concrete European solidarity it's also
in this context that we decided to speed
up work on the civil protection
mechanism at our eu27 working lunch
today we had a good discussion on brexit
which once again reconfirmed our full
unity
let me highlight three points first we
reconfirmed that there will be no
withdrawal agreement without a solid
operational and legally binding Irish
backstop and we continue to fully
support Michel Barnier
in his efforts to find such a model
second we agreed to have a joint
political declaration that provides as
much clarity as possible on the future
relations everybody shares the view that
while there are positive elements in the
checkers proposal the suggested
framework for economic cooperation will
not work not least because it risks
undermining the single market
third we also discussed the timetable
for further negotiations the moment of
truth for bracket negotiations will be
the October European Council in October
we expect maximum progress and results
in the bracket talks then we will decide
whether conditions are the two : extra
summit in November to finalize and
formalize the deal last but not least
again Thank You Sebastian for your
efforts here in the artbook and during
the Austrian presidency we all I think
not only jean-claude and myself we are
really impressed of what you have
achieved
thank you very much thank you and now
the President of the European Commission
jean-claude Juncker - affirmative
gentlemen almost everything has been
sent almost but I'd like to make a few
additional comments this was useful and
also positive informal summit
positive and useful because the federal
chancellor prepared this very carefully
and sounded out the member states the
present the council and the federal
chancellor has consulted us intensively
over the last few weeks months that's
why we were able to work so swiftly I'm
glad that some proposals which the
Commission presented last week received
broad support although there are
detailed aspects which still have to be
discussed further questions still arise
but I can give the example of
getting rid of content advocating
terrorism which should be withdrawn from
the Internet as soon as possible that
proposal has been accepted and the
question of
combating terrorism by working together
of the European prosecutor and national
prosecutors that was fully supported by
everybody although their detailed
questions still arise I'm very
optimistic now I wasn't before about the
external protection of borders where
we've made progress not everyone agrees
with all the details of the Commission's
proposals but there is a basic consensus
thanks to the efforts in Austria in
particular I refer to the coast and
border guard further progress will be
made I think that conclusions can be
reached during the Austrian presidency
and the same applies to the
reinforcement of
catastrophe natural disaster prevention
[Music]
the we presented proposed from 2017 we
know what happened in the summer we
think that there will be support so I
have every reason to thank the
Chancellor for the good work of the
Austrian presence II and I'm glad that
we would do this in salzburg salzburg is
a guarantee of success there are lots of
summits and every some it's more
beautiful than the other summits but I
don't need a summit to come to Salzburg
I'm here once a year and I'm very fond
of Austria
this is a declaration of love so all
that is well and fine
and things will be better still open the
floor for your questions and I see the
first question here in the first row to
the right microphone something may give
on Egypt
you said Egypt is not going to opt for
refugee centers does that mean that in
Egypt you see no opportunity of setting
up these so-called disembarkation
platforms there or why should a country
be proud of the fact that nobody is
leaving that country anymore why would
they want to set up a platform then from
which people from other countries would
be sent back okay well I think you need
to be
cautious when it comes to the rather
curious expression
disembarkation platform we've still
trying to figure out who came up with
that in the first place but it's not
really necessary for resolving the issue
of illegal migration what we've got to
do is basically ensure that as few
people as possible
illegally leaved northern African states
and head for Europe basically the issue
is that if they do then the the issue
should be dealt with as close to the
north african coast as possible above
and beyond that if then it's not
possible to carry out the rescue close
to the coast but on the high seas the
question is then who does the rescuing
it's only when people arrive in our
coastal waters and that the rescue takes
place there only then is the European
Union legally bound and obliged to bring
these people to your it if you take a
look at where the rescues are taking
place now almost no rescue action is
taking place near the coast of regions
of the European Union countries but
quite often or mostly very close to the
north african coast the ngos sometimes
sail into those coastal waters and
indeed in the case of the aquarius what
we have found is that some have
expressed the suspicion that there is at
least an informal kind of an arrangement
with the smugglers and aquarius is
attempting to preempt rescue by the
Libyan Coast Guard not only to rescue
lives but in particular to bring people
to Europe rather than having them
brought back to Libya and if that's
criticized by say the Maltese Prime
Minister he is perfectly right so don't
make the mistake of classifying him as a
right-wing populist because of his
opinion he's a social democrat but he is
perfectly right to criticize what is
happening
in the Mediterranean in this way and if
you look at the number of deaths nobody
can claim that this policy has saved
lives because there were never as many
deaths in the Mediterranean eyes in the
past few years so the system does need
to be changed completely this change to
a new system can only be initiated if
we've got strong partners in northern
Africa it's not just an artificial
expression of creation but rather we
need strong North African partners
strong and efficient countries like
Egypt we want others to emulate this we
will support them when it comes to the
country's coast guards so that the
rescue can take place as efficiently as
rapidly as possible in their coastal
waters and ideally as in the case of
Egypt boats would not launch in the
first place that's the objective we are
pursuing there's an objective we have
come much closer to now than we were a
year ago three years ago these ideas
were being condemned as being radical
and right-wing now more and more people
are supporting them we are working in
this direction and I look forward to
every step we take forward Egypt is
efficient Egypt serves as an example
when it comes to comes to combating
illegal migration and smuggling of
persons were grateful third we want to
support the Egyptians and engage in a
dialogue with them on this and on other
issues such as economic development and
economic cooperation and we very much
hope that with other countries in the
North African region we will have the
same success the signs are there the
Member States have shown that they are
willing to support these efforts by
president triskin myself see current
denominator you can call it whatever you
wish but I'm trying to express it in my
own terms and I think they are
appropriate thank you and we take the
next question I believe the lady in the
fifth row Carcharias piece you annex
very much absolu you're right Kathy
Adler BBC in in their way in and around
this informal summit we've heard EU
leaders talk about compromise when it
comes to brexit Prime Minister Cutts
you've mentioned both sides needing to
come together Theresa May feels that she
has come towards EU principles and is
asking when the EU is going to come
towards her and the UK how can you do
that when can you do that and if you
don't over the Irish border issue isn't
there a danger that you're over
guesstimating that Theresa May will back
down that the UK Parliament will accept
it if she does because if that's the
case surely it's a gamble leading to a
No Deal scenario you say that you don't
want a president to ask if you would
kindly answer first thank you everything
is small as clear now first of all and
the festive in fact I think dtdt essence
of European politics we need to
compromise on both sides the city is
very sense of negotiations it must be
clear that there are some issues where
we are not ready to compromise and first
of all this is our four fundamental
freedoms and
singer market this is why we remain
skeptical and critical and comes to this
part of the checkers proposals the Irish
question remains our priority - and for
this we need not only goodwill what we
feel today it's the atmosphere today and
yesterday was much better than 2/3 which
ago but the Irish question needs
something more than only good intentions
I mean we need a tough clear and precise
guarantees and this is why we need more
time and we need more time but our hope
is that we will be ready with this in
October this is for us this is the
condition to continue this process in
November without clear and precise
solution for Irish question and and for
the whole context of our economic future
relations it would be difficult even to
imagine a positive process after October
and we have - I think it's quite easy to
understand that sometimes there is a Mae
and her staff and also on our south side
that we will use sometimes tough
communication you know it's said we
shouldn't hide that that's the obvious
truth that we are in in the middle of
really difficult negotiations it means
that it's also a tough game but today I
you know I I was always very very sad
because of a brexit us at about today I
am a little bit more optimistic when it
comes to positive outcome of our
negotiations and
but unfortunately we can't exclude at
this stage of some No Deal solution
it depends on both sides I mean this DDD
very idea of negotiations okay we go to
the other side of the room here on the
second room please thank you too much
meat Austria Press Agency president 2sq
have said a final decision on the brexit
emergency summit will be made in October
we have heard from various sources
there could be an extra summit on the
17th and the 18th of November
I wonder at this stage can you already
give a confirmation that if an emergency
summit will be decided and this will be
the date and also to president Juncker
and Chancellor chords how do you want to
prepare and step up your contingency
plans for a No Deal scenario in order to
avoid chaos at airports and in everyday
life
a transport of goods etc is there action
needed on the user if we feel that that
we are able to finalize and formalize
our deal in November I will call this
extraordinary meeting but not two not
two not as an emergency but as a
punchline of effective negotiations de
facto and during our walks of European
Council meeting it means that and our
partners were here absolutely clear that
what we need today is a common
determination on both sides - to end our
negotiations in October but for some
legal and formal reasons then we will
need an summit - to formalize this this
this agreement without
October's grand final in a positive
sense of this word there's no there's no
reason to organize a special meeting in
November this is the only condition when
comes to this possible no member summit
and yes if then it would be some family
Saturday and Sunday to be as we need a
positive conclusion I would like us to
have this conclusion being drawn in
October because time is right now from
the Griffith and no deal is not my
working assumption but would it happen
then we are prepared because the
Commission has prepared in detail all
the elements of consequences of a No
Deal which could be intelligible No Deal
so don't worry be happy don't worry
not a lot to add I agree with President
Juncker
that it shouldn't be our goal to reach
no deal I think we have to avoid the
heartbreak sit but of course we are
prepared to all scenarios but I think it
doesn't make sense to now discuss the No
Deal
scenario because I hope that a deal is
the more realistic scenario okay thank
you
yes I conclude the press conference